hi this is presh tallaker in this video
i'm going to teach you how you can
calculate cube roots in your head
why would you ever want to do this
the education secretary nikki morgan was
recently on tv and put on the hot seat
she was asked by 10 year old the
question what is the cube root of 125
she refused to answer any math questions
on tv and i understand that but if she
knew the trick in this video she could
have answered it very quickly and done
many more math
problems so to do the trick you first
have to memorize the cubes of each
number from one to ten
the cube of a number is the number
multiplied by itself three times
so the cube of one is still 1 the cube
of 2 is 8.
the cube of 3 is 27
and i'm gonna keep writing the cubes of
each number
so you may know some of these otherwise
to do this trick you'll have to memorize
these 10 numbers
now once we've written down these cubes
i want you to focus on the very last
digit of the number of the cube
so what's important is that each of
these 10 numbers
end in a different last digit
and that'll be very important to doing
this trick
so this will be another thing you have
to memorize when you memorize these 10
digits you should also remember the last
digit so an easy way to remember this is
that for the numbers 1 4 5 6 9 and 0 the
last digit is the same as the numbers
and for the numbers 2 and 8 and 3 and 7
the last digit flips so the last digit
for two is eight and the last digit for
three is seven and vice versa so let's
do the trick what's the cube root of
thirty nine thousand three hundred and
four
the first thing i want you to do is look
at the last digit
the last digit of thirty nine thousand
three hundred and four is four
which we're going to put in a box so we
look up four in the last digit
and that corresponds to the number four
so we write down the number four
the next step is we ignore the last
three digits of our number so in 39 304
we're going to just ignore the 304
and now we want to find the closest cube
without going over
so 39 is between 27 and 64.
so it's actually closest to 27 without
going over which means it's closest to
the cube of three
and that gives us the other part of our
answer which is three
so here we have it we put the numbers
together and 34 is the cube root of 39
304
[Music]
so why would this ever be useful so
here's a trick you can do
ask someone to pick a number from one to
a hundred and just think about it
secretly don't have them tell you the
number
have them cube the number on a
calculator
and ha once they cube the number they
tell you the cube and you instantly can
tell them the cube root by using this
table and using the trick
so let's imagine they tell you the
number is
636 056
so we look at the last digit which is
six
and when the last digit is six that
corresponds to the number six
and then we look at the we ignored the
last three digits and we look at 636
that's between the cubes of eight and
nine so we put eight
and therefore the cube root is
eighty-six
so once you get use once you've
memorized this table it'll actually be
able to do this very quickly let's do
another example
185
193
we look at the last digit of three
that corresponds to the number seven
because three and seven flip
then we ignore the last three digits and
we look at 185
and that's closest to the cube of five
without going over
so that gives us the answer of 57
so it's a pretty neat trick
and if you want to know how this works
you can click through i've made a short
video which gives the math crew
if you like this video please subscribe
to my channel
you can support me on patreon to get
exclusive rewards catch me on my blog
mind your decisions on twitter at
preshellwalker and you can get my books
listed on my website